Beyonce's new clothing line Ivy Park has
come under fire recently after tabloid
reports the line was made by workers in
Sri Lanka who are paid only 64 cents an
hour while Ivy Park has denied these
claims this left us wondering about the
clothes we buy from the brands we love
what impact do our purchases have on the
people who make our clothes and do we
even know where our clothes are made
let's find out you know where the
clothes that you're currently wearing
what country they were made in van I
have no idea I don't know think Thailand
and China it's probably China China
maybe Thailand Indonesia USA China China
China China
it's probably like made in a sweatshop
right that's what we're getting at can
we do some investigation I made sure and
I look at your tags you might says Made
in Mexico oh can I check your tag made
in Pakistan all times it's not okay what
about your estimation these are mainly
made in California USA on your yeah
China in Vietnam
oh nicaragua nicaraguan Vietnam made in
Haiti oh it's a made in Russia Nigeria
Pakistan okay thank you Tish El Salvador
Haiti made in China also made in China
Mexico China Vietnam
yeah maybe was amazing the other state
but that that doesn't mean that it made
in United States either yeah you think
so why is that you know as if it's made
in the United States you don't believe
it no way Oh
most of our clothes is coming from out
of the country we with a lost our
manufacturing